the supposed co-front Runner Ron
DeSantis is weaker than it seems there's
a poll out from NBC News you know about
the chrysosons I've talked to you about
the potential criticons right now Trump
is at 51 percent DeSantis is at 22 Pence
is at six percent Christie's right
behind it five percent Haley at four
percent Tim Scott three percent of
vacant three percent even ASA Hutchinson
at two percent how how has the movement
been on those numbers Trump is up five
points from April Pence is up one point
Christie is up Five Points as I told you
would happen the big change here is
DeSantis is down nine percent Chris
Christie is not taking votes from Donald
Trump Chris Christie is taking votes
from Ron DeSantis
because as I've said from the beginning
the big trouble for Rhonda Santos is
that he is running in the Trump Lane he
is the Trump candidate his pitches on
Trump 2.0 I'm Trump without the
weaknesses his big base of support is
going to come from people who don't
really like Trump all that much